Nitz jelly-filled doughnuts this is just
a doughnut oh god I'm gonna throw up
hey everyone my name is Matt bellezza
and this is whine about it a weekly
video series where I get drunk at my
desk and complain about stuff on this
week's episode types of foods that are
the worst sol eat almost anything except
for most things let's drink
okay here he comes
okay that's alright let's give this
started
what sushi sushi is a lot of food sushi
is my foods food sushi is like if
Finding Nemo got stuck in a seaweed
forest someone chopped him up in a
little tiny pieces and wrapped him up in
a little rice sleeve it's all slimy and
tiny and you got any 3000 of them in
order to feel full that's what your
sushi is to blue cheese bow cheese just
multi bellybutton cheese that's all with
us but everybody who eats blue cheese
they just say oh you know what you know
would make my salad better if it tastes
like a moldy dick next kale his leaves
didn't taste bad enough someone was like
let's give him [ __ ] kale a little
they'll love it it's sharp it's all
leafy its greener than normal leaves for
some reason it's like eating that even a
handful of leafy glass did you take your
kale and shove it right down the sewer
drain it float it up for
also cookies with raisins in them you
know a raisin s raise it as a chocolate
Shepherd gave up all its hopes and
dreams settle a bit of race it also
dried fruit booth clicked out of fruit
say you know be you know it be good you
know be awesome fighter sucked every
piece of moisturizer let's peace fruit
oh you know I would love it if I could
swallow us banana but it's scratched my
throat all the way down I love it if I
just
deep throat the sandy dry banana they
try to make you think it's good because
they may because they call it a chip
look call it an apple chip or peach chip
or apricot chip it's not a chip you know
it's a [ __ ] chip a chip you eat your
fruit sweat like everything else next
creamy peanut butter creamy peanut
butter is like if a full-grown man
shaves off all his pubes what's left
there's nothing there's nothing left to
the imagination
next Robin look at him [ __ ] noodle is a
ramen a ramen is just a spaghetti noodle
that went for a perm
Robin next hash browns well cheating
hash browns with your breakfast hash
browns don't go well with breakfast
bunch of dry shedded flakes of potato no
you can write off with your burnt hash
brown flakes next pretzel buns these are
too hard to bite only tasty pretzel next
cauliflower with its cauliflower I mean
it doesn't taste like anything that's
all cauliflower is such a scary ghost
broccoli what is it thinking you have no
idea next zucchini pasta that's not
pasta oh oh you don't have to have carbs
you be healthy eat the vegetable and you
your brain won't even know uh he'll know
Barbara
just cause you shaved zucchini down a
shredder doesn't mean my brains gonna
think he's got a delicious the town
priest why don't you take your zucchini
and shove it where it belongs
anywhere but my face next cookie cake
are you a cookie or are you cake you
piece of [ __ ] next
jelly-filled doughnuts joyful doughnuts
are just doughnuts on their period it's
a doughnut not a tampon then finally
many foods who though looks at a food
and thinks you don't be great you know
what I would love less of this just a
little bit I could carry around in my
pocket that's what I say people like
mini foods you know what you need bigger
pockets your mini buffets your fudge
your sushi your putti good mustard all
of it
all right everybody thank you for
watching this week as always you can
find our videos every week on
whineaboutit.tumblr.com and my page
which is facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt and
you find our videos on youtube on
youtube.com slash BuzzFeed video but
that's it that's everything
you know what everyone should do vote
for me
we're People's Choice Award we're fair
social media star cuz I get drunk at my
desk every week and kill myself for you
[ __ ] if you don't vote for me
I'll just die alone with no Awards